in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
americans is really far greater than
what divides us so this morning we're
focusing on the homes where dr martin
luther king jr once dreamed of a
brighter future and the man who helped
further his vision cbs this morning
saturday co-host michelle miller is at
the atlanta house where the civil rights
icon was born michelle good morning
good morning more than 700 000 people
come here every single year to visit the
home where the reverend dr martin luther
king jr was born this was his living
room that's a picture of his
grandparents now the national parks
foundation purchased this home for 1.9
million dollars late last year thanks to
an anonymous donor who's not so
anonymous
anymore
welcome to the canberra hall the
descendants of the reverend dr martin
luther king jr have held down this
homestead for generations all the
children were born in here all the
children now they're entrusting the
birthplace of the civil rights icon to
the national park service this is mr
robert frederick smith thanks to the one
synonymous donor robert f smith this
is almost a full circle moment for you
my mother
you know took me to the march in
washington i was nine months old of
course i don't remember any of it but i
remember the every day of ours growing
up
and the lessons that her and my father
you know brought into the home he first
toured the king home a few months ago i
tell you what struck me was actually the
dining room table
the dynamic of family together and
that's a chance where the families can
interact and engage talk about the
topics that are relevant to us as people
the ethic of love he really got that
here we were lucky enough to experience
a rare multi-generational family reunion
in that very same room albeit with
museum prop cuisine everybody sat at
dinner every night everybody came to
dinner
at the same time right why
why
i mean i guess it was a tradition this
was an opportunity for
my father her mother
naomi's husband to be able to talk as
children and even ask questions
and that was just unheard of at that
time the house purchase was made through
contributions from the fund to
foundation which smith founded the
organization has donated more than 40
million dollars to preserve african
american culture through the national
parks which includes buying the homes of
frederick douglass harriet tubman and
booker t washington smith also
personally gifted 20 million dollars to
the national museum of african american
history and culture in washington d.c
sounds like mr mr smith you're on a
mission i am i truly am i think a big
part of that mission is to educate the
world
as to what african americans have
contributed in america and educate
americans as to what our contributions
have led to and so many great things
that make america the unique place it is
on the planet the park service will not
only preserve two of king's former
atlanta homes it will record and share
family memories including contributions
from everyone at this table we've been
through a lot here's a preview
what don't people know about dr king
that they should
this is one thing i tell young people dr
king was a c student at morehouse he got
a c in public speaking he got a c in
preaching at crozier
it tells you that you don't allow
grades and people's judgments even to
define who you are and what you're going
to contribute to this world and he just
continued to push forward and did not
let it discourage him this is a
demonstration of progress that is
definitely being made he really was not
puffed up right right
he wasn't um socially awkward
right
he was um
unpretentious honest and plain i think
that they will you know in the family
will find a wonderful you know
opportunity as we as we finish what i
call the digitization efforts to
experience their life though the king
family agree handing over their
ancestral home was the right thing to do
actually doing it wasn't an easy
decision it took me a minute right
because we were raised
to understand ownership i was so i had
to get in my head wait a minute
this is not how we need to expend our
energy
because i was initially like no i don't
want to
transfer sale my mother's home when you
think about what mr robert smith has
done what does that mean to you and
putting your old family home back
together
to me it means it won't be lost
i mean the tangible property is
important it will always be important
but it's also important that more and
more people
know the true stories
and dr king's daughter bernice told me
she's already gone through all of her
personal effects
those will be digitized downloaded into
a database so that people from anywhere
in the world can have their very own 3d
experience bianna michelle that was like
a history lesson it learned so much
dr king first of all he was a c student
i'm very surprised at that imagine it
gives a lot of people hope we were
sitting out there nobody wants to get
seizo when you can get bees or a's but
it does show you that your grades quite
often don't define the intelligence that
you have and thank you to robert smith
what a wonderful thing that he's doing
highlighting the importance of dinner
conversations exactly together at the
table exactly
morning and night